Ecuador superó la tasa de muertes
violentas de la región según datos de
las Naciones Unidas e información de la
policía nacional ecuatoriana revelada el
día de hoy que lo ubica en uno de los
países más violentos de la región con 25
muertes violentas por casi mil
habitantes según datos de la Policía
Nacional el año 2022 en el país andino
se produjeron 4.539 homicidios lo que
representa un incremento de 114% en
comparación al año 2021 cuando la tasa
de muerte se contabilizó en 12 por cada
100,000 habitantes cuatro delitos
caracterizan el incremento de la
violencia en Ecuador asesinato sicariato
homicidio y femicidio en su mayoría
relacionadas con el crimen organizado y
la lucha de territorio para el
narcotráfico la tendencia de crecimiento
de los homicidios en el país pasó de 5,4
en el año 2017 a 25 por cada 100.000
habitantes en el año 2022 el año más
violento de la historia de Ecuador la
tasa de América Latina es de 18 muertes
según las Naciones Unidas mientras que
Ecuador ya superó la tasa a 25 muertes
por cada 100.000 habitantes
Mientras que el 3 de enero de 2023 ya se
produjo la primera muerte violenta por
impacto de bala de un hombre en la
provincia de Santo Domingo de los
tsáchilas los especialistas aseguran que
las cifras aumentarán durante el año en
curso si el estado no toma políticas de
seguridad más contu